Hey, there.
My name Is Brett Slatkin, and
I'm a software engineer on the
Google Surveys Team.
I'm here today to tell you
about the secret to safe,
continuous deployment.
You can find me online
at onebigfluke.com.
So here's our agenda
for today.
We're going to talk about the
why and how of continuous
deployment.
I'm going to talk to you about
making mistakes while doing
continuous deployment.
Then we're going to talk about
how to be safe while
you're doing it.
And then finally, I'm going to
show you some examples of our
team being safe with continuous
deployment.
So the why and how.
This is your typical software
release process on a team.
You write your code.
You commit it to your source
code repository.
And at that point, you're really
happy, and you have a
lot of motivation, because
you've gotten
this feature to work.
You branch the code.
You maybe push it to
a staging server.
And then you get to see it
kind of live in a mostly
production deployment.
But then after that, nothing
happens for weeks.
There's a release schedule, and
it doesn't actually get
launched until everybody's
ready, and the bus is leaving
the station.
So what I found on the App
Engine team is that we would
have this release process that,
to me, it was really
hard to stay motivated, because
the time from when I
wrote the code to when it hit
production was so long.
I would be happiest when
I wrote the code, and
when I saw it live.
Now while I was working on App
Engine, I was also working on
PubSubHubbub.
This was an open source project,
so we would push this
to production every two days.
So in the span of time that it
would take one release for App
Engine, we could do 10
for PubSubHubbub.
And that made me really happy.
I realized that seeing my code
live is what made me happy.
And then that reminds of this
quote from Ian Bicking, who
works in Mozilla.
And he said, "When it comes to
deployment, App Engine is the
first thing that has really felt
good to me." And that's
what really kind of brought
it all together.
I was working on App Engine
infrastructure.
I was also building an
app using App Engine.
App Engine is great
for deployment.
It makes it very easy
to deploy your app.
And that's what I found was what
made me the most happy
about PubSubHubbub.
I just loved writing the
code and deploying
it as fast as possible.
So I was browsing the web one
day and I came across this
article by Timothy Fitz, called
"Continuous Deployment
at IMVU," which is a start-up,
"Doing the Impossible 50 Times
A Day." And the process he
describes reminds me a lot of
the tool that we had,
appcfg update.
They made it ridiculously easy
to deploy their software to
production.
They would do it all the time.
And I thought, I could use the
same tool to do the same kind
of thing very easily.
But I never had.
So then, we were starting this
new project called Google
Consumer Surveys.
And like any new software team,
we were deciding on the
stack that we wanted to use
to build the software.
So we wanted to use
Django and Python.
We wanted to use Closure
Library.
We wanted to use App Engine, and
JavaScript, and HTML5, and
everything that it
has to offer.
But we thought, if we're going
to be deliberate about our
software stack, maybe we should
be deliberate about our
processes beyond that, such
as deployment or testing.
And so we did that.
So we adopted this as our
process for continuous
deployment.
It's a kind of serial
test and push.
It's kind of your textbook
example of continuous
deployment.
So someone writes the code.
You do code review
with a peer.
You check it into revision
control.
Once it's in revision control,
you run automated tests to
make sure that your code's
passing tests.
Then you automate deploying
to a staging server.
Then later on, some other person
looks at the staging
version, makes sure that
it looks good.
And if it does, they set that
version to live, or make it
the default version.
So now we've been doing
this for over a year.
It's been working really well.
And so here's a kind of a plot
of the number of deployments
that we do over the year.
And this is the number of
deployments per day.
So you can see we've peaked at
40 deployments in one day.
You can see that where
the graph goes
to zero is the weekends.
And you can see our average
number of deployments per day
is actually very
good over time.
Here's another graph, which
shows how long a version stays
live in production after
we've pushed it.
And you can see on average
during the week, it's less
than 24 hours, which means that
we're constantly pushing
new versions during
business hours.
And then on the weekends,
we don't push software.
And you can see our time to
deployment goes over 24 hours
to three days.
So that was working
great, until we
started making some mistakes.
And here it is.
So I pushed a pony to production
for all of our
paying customers.
This is one of the stupidest
things I've
done in a long time.
The whole idea was that it
was supposed to indicate
experimental features.
A lot of engineers call features
that you want, the
pony features, something
like that.
That's what we were
trying to do here.
I didn't realize that it would
be enabled for all users.
I thought it would only be
for administrative users.
But it turns out, I pushed
it for everybody.
And that was a big mistake.
When you talk to people who
work in dev ops and do any
kind of system administration
at all, this is their
nightmare scenario, this idea
of having a pony in
production.
It's just embarrassing to the
product for your users.
And I did this.
And that was a big mistake.
And it's not like we
didn't have tests.
Like I said before, we had
automated tests to make sure
that everything was good.
But nothing actually tested the
site to say like, is there
a pony dancing on the
screen on that page?
It's like, no, didn't
test that.
Didn't think about that one.
We also had all kinds of
monitoring and graphs.
We knew our error rates for
data store operations, and
JavaScript client errors,
and so on.
But none of that would surface
a dancing pony on the screen.
And so here are the things
we tried and failed.
We had monitoring.
We did test and automation.
We had continuous integration
of our source code.
We did peer code review.
We deployed this to staging
even, and we
saw the pony on staging.
But the pony was expected
behavior on staging.
We couldn't tell the difference
between the staging
behavior and the production
behavior.
So that didn't work.
And then having a QA checklist
wouldn't have caught the pony,
because it's not like, make sure
there's no pony on this
screen for this thing.
It just would've failed.
So all the ideas we
had didn't work.
But then we came up with
this other idea.
And this is the secret
I'm talking about.
How to be safe.
So what you're looking at here
is something you may not have
seen before.
It's called the perceptual
diff.
It's a perceptual difference.
It's kind of like a diff on
files that you've changed when
you've written code.
But it's for the pixels on the
screen as part of the website.
So on the left is an old
version of this page.
On the right is a new version
of this page.
And what you'll notice is that
it's almost humanly impossible
to tell the difference
between the two.
It's kind of like "Where's
Waldo?" It's going to take you
a long time to find the actual
pick it out, the actual
difference.
It's next to the globe.
It was something to do with the
way that the pricing was
indicated on our page here.
And I have it highlighted
in red below.
Because what we did is we hooked
up a system for doing
this with a computer.
So computers are really
good at detecting
changes like this.
And so we let the computer
do the work for us.
And it was able to do a
screenshot of the page on the
left, a screenshot of the page
on the right, and then diff
the two perceptually, and
show us what's changed.
And that's what's in
red at the bottom.
Here's another example
of the same thing.
This is our reporting interface
on the left.
And on that page, there's
a mistake.
There's a problem
with the build.
It's down on the bottom left.
There's a histogram
of response times.
It's pulled out here
on the right.
So you can see what we expected
on the top was 0 to
60 seconds response time.
What we found was the x-axis
was totally garbled.
And what's awesome is that
perceptual diffs are able to
automatically pick out this
change and show that to you,
which is highlighted
in red below.
So we're using a tool now to
do this that automates this
process for many, many different
parts of our website
to figure out, how is it
changed, and have we regressed
in any way that's hard
for a human to see?
So again, we screenshot the
old release that's live in
production.
We screenshot the new release
that's on the staging version,
hopefully using the same
data, if possible.
We pair the URL paths together
so that we're comparing--
even though the host names
are different, the
paths are the same.
And then we visually
diff the pixels.
So we tried this a few
times for different
parts of our site.
We were actually just doing this
big refactoring of some
of our user-facing code.
And we wanted to make sure that
it was visually exactly
what it had been before.
But we thought, why don't we
just use this for everything?
Why don't we use visual diffs
for every single part of our
application?
So we have.
So here is our old
process before.
And now we've modified it to
add this parallel step.
Once the code hits revision
control, we deploy it to
staging at the same time that
we run automated tests.
And then we also do perceptual
diff tests at the same time.
So the release pusher who's
deciding, is this release
ready to go or not, they look
at the test results of the
unit tests and the integration
tests.
But they also look at the
perceptual diff tests, and
they say, has my site visually
changed in a way that I did
not expect?
And if it hasn't, then you set
the version live, and you're
good to go.
So let me give you some
examples of pdiffs.
I think it's really interesting
to see the types
of problems you can
find doing this.
And so I'm going to highlight
a few of them.
OK.
So the first of these are things
you'd expect to see.
So here, we added a button, this
little building button up
at the top.
And here's the pdiff.
So on the left, there's the
building button on the right.
That's before there was
no building button.
So we added it.
You can see the diff.
Here's one when the Giants
won the World Series.
And it was Halloween, and we
thought, hey, let's do
something silly.
We're based in the San Francisco
office, so we ended
up putting some Giants
colors on here.
Did that for a day.
That was an expected change.
Here's another one, where
we totally revamped the
Confirmation page for
our billing flow.
And you can see on the left is
how it used to be with this
gray kind of box.
And on the right is the new
way we have it, where it's
kind of laid out in a grid.
At the bottom, you
can see the diff.
All of the different pieces
totally changed.
Very obvious diff.
Here's another one, where we
started doing surveys along
with the Harris Poll.
And we had a promotion
that it totally
changed on our home page.
Pdiff totally picked this up.
And that was pretty easy.
Where it starts getting
interesting is cases like
this, where it's less obvious.
When you first glance at these
two, it's really hard to tell
what's changed.
What's changed is at the top,
you'll see that now there's
three steps instead
of four steps.
So pdiff is able to pick
that out really easily.
That's another feature launch.
Pdiff can also pick out this
color changing on the map.
We had all blues before.
It was really hard to see, so
we changed the color scheme.
So it picked out that all of
that had changed, even thought
it was just by a little bit.
And then we also have another
feature launched here, where
we added frequency
to our surveys.
So that's kind of the bigger,
chunkier changes.
What's interesting is
the ones you can't
really see as a human.
So on the left, the padding
on top of this div
changed by 40 pixels.
The diff showed that
it had shifted.
And if you look at it visually,
now you can see that.
But you really couldn't pick
that up unless you were
expecting it to be there.
And this is something that
pdiff is very good at.
It's regressions.
It's very good at.
Here's another one.
These are two different versions
of the same chart.
They look still to
me identical.
But we subtly changed the way
that the bar width calculation
was made, and the spacing
between the
labels and the bars.
And pdiff totally picked this
up, and showed actually it's a
huge change.
But it's almost impossible
to see as a human.
Here's another one.
We had a table of information.
People glaze over when they're
looking at tables of data.
And we lost the Midwest and
regional bias table.
And pdiff was able to pick this
up and show us like, hey,
this thing totally moved,
and you lost this.
And it turns out it was a
bug, and we had to go
back and fix it.
And then here's one
of my favorites.
We changed it so there's a
single pixel line above the
charts that moved.
That's it.
So pdiff saw this single pixel
line and made us realize we
had a regression.
The diff below is actually
very large.
But to a human, it's almost
impossible to see that this
has changed.
So that was like, a really
helpful one.
So the subtle differences is
what it gets really well.
Here's another example, where
the sort order changed on this
from lexical to numerical,
or numerical to lexical.
And it's another example of,
a human wouldn't see this.
We just glaze past it.
And pdiff can see
it really well.
And so finally, we're using
diff for everything now.
We even diff the emails that
we send to our customers as
part of our onboarding flow
and the purchase flows.
So this is an actual rendering
of an email that we would send
to a customer, and we diff it on
every release to make sure
that those emails look good and
don't change over time.
Because once you send an email,
you can't take it back.
So anyway, the conclusion of
all this is that pdiffs are
the best thing.
If you have anyone you've ever
worked with who says, well, we
can't do continuous deployment
because it's not safe, this is
the thing for you.
Perceptual diffs are what make
it possible to do it safely.
And that's what you should
be looking at.
There's a lot of great tools
now if you're doing this.
PhantomJS is the big one.
So PhantomJS is a WebKit build
that does this-- it's a
headless WebKit that
does screenshots.
Slimer's the same thing for
Firefox and the Gecko engine.
And then PhantomCSS is a kind of
nice wrapper around this to
make it easy for CSS refactoring
changes.
You can do all kinds of
integration with Jenkins, and
Travis-CI, and CircleCI, and
there's many others, to do the
actual build and release
process.
And then for deployment, there's
a lot of companies
that are doing deployment
right now.
A few open source projects.
But generally, we need more
continuous deployment tools,
in my opinion.
There's also an open source
project that I'm working on.
It's called dpxdt.
You can find it on GitHub.
And that project's still just
starting out, but we're making
some progress to make this
tool really easy
for anyone to use.
And then, you're more than
welcome to check out my day
job on g.co/consumersurveys of
where we're using continuous
deployment and perceptual diffs,
building our product
and releasing all the time.
So thanks.
That's all I have
to say today.
And thanks for listening.